[音楽]
映画やドラマの中で
この物語の中で
観客は
登場人物とともにその世界を生きています
この世界の中には
登場人物の感情が大きく動くシーンや
観客が
登場人物に深く感情移入するシーンそう
いった素晴らしいお芝居がたくさんあり
ます
しかしもしそれが
俳優やスタッフの負担の上で
撮影されているとしたら皆さんどう思われ
ますか
涙が止まらないほど感動した
撮影の裏で
俳優がもし生涯立ち直れないような
ダメージを受けていたらどうします
うつがあれば事故につながるような
アクションシーンは入念に確認がされるの
に
同じく体の接触を伴うキスシーンや性的な
描写その写真はじゃあやってみようかと
俳優の経験値に任されてしまうことがある
の
です俳優たちは何の確認も
承諾も求められないまま
拒否どころか
相談することもできないまま見過ごされて
いることもあるの
私はインティマシーコーディネーターと
いう仕事をしています
皆さんその名称は耳にされたことはあり
ますか
インシマシーコーディネーターとは
映像制作において
飯島真意と呼ばれる
ヌードや性的な描写を
俳優の
身体的精神的安心安全を守りつつ
監督のビジョン
監督の求めるビジョンを最大限実現する
ためにサポートするスタッフです
昨年話題のドラマに参加したことや
リンゴ流行語大賞にノミネートされたこと
もあって
見る側の皆さんにその名称を知って
いただくことができました
アメリカで始まったこのインスマシー
コーディネーターという職業は
2017年の飲酒運動で
需要に拍車がかかりました
日本に導入されたのは2年半前
女性の俳優の
希望によるものでし
たアメリカを筆頭に
欧米諸国には
俳優組合がありますが日本には
俳優組合もないそして
映像制作における取得もありません
それにより
俳優やスタッフの人権が
登場されることが少ない現場になってい
ます
私はその要因として
芸術だから映画だからというそれによって
許されている何かといった考えが根底に
あると思い
回遊も生身の人間でお芝居を通じて別の
人物を演じているだけで
俳優自身の人格と感情がそこにあるのは
言うまでもありません
身体的精神的許容範囲は
俳優本人が決めるものであって他の誰かが
決めることではありません
仕事だからといって彼らの意志が尊重され
ず人権が無視されるようなことがあっては
なりません
私の受けた
飯島市コーディネーターを養成する
トレーニングの中で私が最も
印象深かったのは同意を得ることの大切さ
です日本にもノーという言葉が苦手で
曖昧のままな状況それを好む傾向があると
思います
相手の同意を得るというとても大事な
ステップが
うやむやのままになっていてもあまり違和
感を感じないの
先ほどお話ししたようにあたかも
殴られているかのようなアクションシーン
東京芝居は入念な確認があります
それは事故や怪我があってはならないから
です
ところがキスシーンやお互いに触れ合って
愛を確かめ合うシーンはとりあえずやって
みてが多いのです
同じ体の接触を伴ったお芝居であるにも
関わらずなぜそこだけ肺炎の経験に任せる
のでしょう
お互いの体に
意志を持って接触するのであれば私はそこ
に同意が必要だと思います
俳優の経験がその方のお芝居に行ってくる
ことは間違いありません
ですが
脚本と演出を実行しそこにその俳優の感性
と演技がプラスされればその人にその人に
しかできないお芝居になるのではない
でしょうか
とりあえずやってみるという
俳優の経験値に任せ共演者との同意確認も
ないまま動きませんの撮影に包むことは
俳優の
極めてプライベートな部分を出すことを
強調し教養し
偶発的に生まれる共演者の間のサミットに
ばかりを求め
俳優が心に
傷を負う可能性のある行為だと思います
必要なのはそのシーンを演じるための演出
や物質動きそれに三種の同意と共演者の間
での確認
許容範囲の確認が同意をもう一度確認する
ことに
もその確認の上で
俳優は安心して最高のパフォーマンスを
出せるのではないでしょうか
例えば台本の中にキスをする二人という
表現があったとします
そういったものとがきと言うんですが
というのは
登場人物のセリフ以外の心臓や行動を指示
するものです
キスをする二人
その前後の描写にもよりますがその
施設は
濃厚で激しいものなのか
そもそも唇と唇を合わせる傷なのかそれと
もほっぺたなどへの
皮膚なの
かミスをしている時のお互いの体の体勢は
どうでしょう
抱きしめ合っているのか顔に手を触れて
いるのか
それとも
抱きしめあって
腰に手が回っているのか
ミス一つを取っても様々な表現がありその
表現をすることが可能なのか
俳優に確認をする必要があります
この確認をして同意を得る
同意を得たことしか撮影しない
そういったサポートをするのが人気マシン
コーディネーターの仕事です
メンテナシーコーディネーターの仕事をし
ていて気づくことがあります
俳優が自分自身で選択して同意することで
自信を持ってお芝居をしているように
見受けられます
脚本を読む役をオファーされた段階で
求められてることは理解していると思い
ます
ただその理解を認識が製作陣と違うことも
あります
監督が望むその描写を不安を感じながら
演じるのではなく
理解の共通にして
納得して同意して
演じることで
やりがいや地震そういったものに
満ち溢れたお芝居になるんだと思い
不安なく集中して演じたその
パフォーマンスはより良い作品を
作り上げると私は信じています
女性だから
男性だから
俳優だから仕事だからと無限にされてきた
この同意を得るという行為
ここ数年で大事なものだと
捉えられるようになってきました
インチマシーコーディネーターの導入も
その表れだと思います
この変化からもわかるように少しずつです
が個人の意見を伝えることができそれを
受け入れる土壌が出てきたりできてきたと
思います
それぞれの意見が
尊重するべきだれるべきだという思想が
広がっているんだと思います
真面目な性格で
相手や周りに気を使い
空気を読む人ほど
ノーというのが難しい
傾向があります
監督の期待に応えたい自分はできないと
いうことで
迷惑をかけてしまっ
こんなことができないなんて自分はプロの
俳優なのに自分を責めてしまう可能性が
高いのです
準備をしてくれているスタッフの努力
頑張りを無下にしてはいけないそういった
責任感
またはその時の高揚感だけで正しい
判断ができないまま
撮影に挑んでしまった方もいるかと思い
ます
俳優の生涯が終わっても
その時に無理をした家
プレッシャーによって言わされてしまった
家
それは作品の中で
永遠に生き続けます
このイエスを生み出してしまう環境は
被害者の心に大きな傷を負わせるだけで
なく
その作品そのものを価値を下げてしまうと
思います
作品に関わる全てのスタッフキャストそれ
からそれを見てくださっているお客さん
みんなに対してこれはある日の裏切りに
なってしまうのではないでしょうか
嬉しいことに
映画の観客は作品を選ぶ時の理由として
俳優や
撮影環境の安全性を掲げる人が増えてき
ました
解釈一人一人のリテラシーが高くなること
は製作者の一種も高めます
それによって作品も洗練されていきます
インティマシーシーンが安全に撮影された
かどうかだけでなく
映像業界の
劣悪な労働環境も大きな問題です
観客を無意識のうちに
各種する側にしてしまうことを映画制作者
は
辞めなくてはいけませんそれと同時に皆
さんも関心を持ってください
その関心が映画業界を変えていきます
2021年の夏にジャパニーズフィルム
プロジェクトは日本映画
協会の
警察現場の
ジェンダー調査を行いました
2000年から2020年の対策映画に
おける日本の映画監督のジェンダー比率を
見ると女性
監督の比率はたったの酸素に1%です
男性監督が多いのは
歴然たる技術です
現代比率97%を占める
男性監督の中には
権力を持ちすぎその権力の使い方も認識を
間違えたまま今に至りそして今もその
そしてその中の多くの方々は今もその過去
を見直していません
そのような
権力に映画業界そのものが抵抗することが
できず
男性は変わらず女性が男性に合わせてきた
という印象を受けます
私の仕事はエンジマシーコーディネーター
ですが現代
ギャップ現代ギャップ指数のランキングが
世界120位の日本に住む日本人女性で
あり
夫とともに7歳の娘を育てる母親でもあり
ます
次の世代の次の世代を担う子供たちが安心
して映画を見ることができてそして安心し
て
夢を持って飛び込んでいけるそんな
エンターテイメント業界を作っていくこと
が私自身の使命であり人気なし
コーディネーターとしての
存在意義の一つでもあります
そして
俳優を志す若者が
搾取されることなく自分の最高の
パフォーマンスを披露できるような世界に
変えていきたいです
一人一人が尊重されるように変わっていか
なくてはいけないのは映画業界に限った
ことではありません
信頼しているからイエスではなく
信頼しているからこそノーと言える
大事なのはその返事がイエスでもNoでも
受け入れてもらえるという信頼関係と
コミュニケーション
高校生における同意もとても大切です
大好きな相手に対してより親密になりたい
という気持ちは多くの方が抱く環境では
ないでしょうか
ただ自分の求める親密さのレベルは相手と
同じでしょうか
相手を大事に思うからこそ自分の本当の
気持ちに蓋をして
イエスと言ってしまう
またイエスと言わせるような
プレッシャーを与えていないでしょうか
自分のそして相手のイエスは心からの心の
底からの遠いでしょうか
同意のある蛍光章に
ジェンダーやセクシャリティーは関係あり
ません
相手を大切にする相手の気持ちを尊重する
そういったことが相手との関係をより深め
そしてより良い関係へと発展させていくの
ではないでしょうか
そして同意の重要性は
成功者に限った話でもありません
自分の気持ちを伝えて相手の気持ちを
受け入れるというシンプルなやり取りは
友達同士家族先輩と後輩上司と部下どの
ような関係においてもとても重要です
お互いが
戸惑うことなく安心って自分の気持ちを
伝えられる
丁寧なコミュニケーションは全ての人間
関係のベースだと思います
では自分ができているかというと私も
まだまだ修行中
です特に
子育てにおいては7歳の子供の気持ちだけ
を尊重するわけにはいかず日が足した縄が
ことの
言い争いは日常茶飯事です
その中でも大切にしているのは彼女の
気持ちに耳を傾けることです
そして自分のコミュニケーションの取り方
が彼女をコントロールしているように感じ
た場合は
すぐに認めて謝ります
何が正しい間違っているではなく一方的に
ならずにお互いの気持ちを伝え合うことが
いかに大切なことか
それを理解しながら成長していけば
独りよがりになることもなく相手のことを
尊重できる人間に
成長していけるのではないかと思ってい
ます自分の希望
理想熱意を伝えることはとても大事なこと
だと思います
ただ自分の熱意と同じくらい相手のことを
尊重することも忘れてはいけません
相手を焦らせたり
萎縮させたり
たとえ自分が求めている同意への返事が
脳であってもそれを受け入れる
そんな信頼関係が築かれるような
丁寧なコミュニケーションを心がけていれ
ば自分の意見を押し付けたり相手を自分の
言いなりにしようという発想は生まれない
のではないでしょうか
自分を認めてもらうこと
それは相手を認めることでもあります
相手の立場に立つと見えてくることが
たくさんあります
答えを決めるのはあなたです
持参が必要であればそれを伝えましょう
相手の本音を知りたいのであればノーと
言える環境を作りましょう
相手が自分が
意見を伝えやすい関係を築きましょう
そしてお互いの気持ちを尊重しましょう
同意を得ることの大切さを
忘れないでください
自分の家相手の脳どちらも大切にして
ください
ありがとうございました